de la mer les thèmes traités
malhonnêtes gens retraite de malhonnête
est ce que vous nous faites un chantage
au suicide j'ai pas dit ça madame c'est
dingue c'est donc vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter
c'est bon là vous aurez version non je
n'aurai pas le temps je le sais déjà
j'ai pas le temps j'ai juste le temps de
mettre en colère ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la jeunesse désespère
elle est profondément profondément
désespéré parce qu'elle n'a plus
d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française
et moi je pense qu est la règle générale
résume en un peu bien raison ce que je
peux lui dire c'est que le désespoir et
mobilisateur et que lorsqu'il devient
mobilisateur il est dangereux et que ça
entraîne le terrorisme la bande à baader
et les choses comme ça mais moi je suis
pas d'accord et vous votre gouvernement
est en guerre nous on n'est pas en
guerre non se fait tirer dessus quand on
va voir des concerts il ya des gens ici
qu'on ait kalachnikov sur eux des armes
les gens ici qui veulent tuer les
musulmans personnes vous êtes en guerre
vos décisions à l'international sont en
garde pas nous mais on n'est pas en
guerre avec moi je suis pas en guerre
contre les musulmans qu'elle vous
trouvez pas qu'il ya une racaille d'en
haut
justement si on veut être respecté il
faut être respectable
les pauvres ils sont vraiment débordés
par une délinquance qui explose c'est
une réalité times qui explose l'un des
leurs collègues se pose à l'évidence
euros j'en ai les violences non
crapuleuses saïd les violences c'est pas
gênant pour vous que ça explose madame
si vous avez un tout petit peu dans la
rue
de merde quoi
[Musique]